I made a joke up top that you're here
pushing this new show friends and it
almost feels in a way like that's a
version of the truth because friends is
on Netflix now and there's this whole
other generation my daughter is watching
friends and she didn't know what friends
was and now she loves friends it feels
like it just keeps going is it you have
that sense it's awesome it's it's kind
of unbelievable you know it does every
generation like every year there's like
some new kids that discover it and even
you know for people that are not
discovering it for the first time it's
like people have called it comfort food
and things like that it's yeah it's kind
of nice yeah yeah do you ever find
yourself in a situation like I don't
know you're going through an airport or
something and Friends is on and you look
up at it and you absolutely have no idea
what is going on in that episode cuz
it's been so long since you did it if
you if you checked in blindly on an
average episode would you say oh wow I
wonder what happens
[Laughter]
yeah well I'm gonna be 97 minutes you
know you were obviously that changed
your life overnight the success of that
show but you were broke when you got
friends isn't that right like seriously
broke yeah I you know when you think all
right I got a little money in the bank I
can I can hold out to the next gig and I
think goes down to $11 well let $11 now
that's holding out too long because even
if I said at that point all right I'm
gonna go get like a like a waiter job
but the time that $11 ran out would have
been before the first paycheck on the
right right you waited too long I
would've starved yeah could you afford a
headshot did you have a headshot at the
time cuz that's the big thing in this
town is you got to have your headshot a
good picture of yourself a lot of times
people say that's the difference between
getting a job or not getting a job yeah
I had I had the same headshot for a long
time
yeah the first the first headshot that I
ever got taken so I went to the
photographer and he said to me he goes
all right you know it's all set up he's
got the cameras and the lights and
everything he says um before we take
this you might want to go and get that
tooth filed I go what did you tell my um
oh yeah because yeah one tooth is a
little longer than the other one I go oh
really did you get that filed I go okay
yeah yeah and then come back so I went
and I you know back when this back when
there was phone booths yeah and the
Yellow Pages yeah so I look up a dentist
no insurance I go to see the guy he says
yeah I could file that for you be about
80 bucks 80 bucks
what well I go what are you gonna do
because I'll just file it I go let me
see the file so he shows it to me and I
go well forget it
don't worry about it so I go to the
drugstore buy like a three pack of Emery
boards
I mean you've filed your own tooth down
yeah
I'm very frugal yeah so when you went
back to the guy What did he say that guy
he goes they did a nice job oh I got a
really good guy he's the best thank God
he didn't say you needed an ID job